[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the 34th live stream of the
dark horse
podcast here from portland oregon the
center of all the confusion in the
universe it would seem
wow i'm right here with dr heather hein
as always and we are going to try to
navigate the confusion and see if we
can't
rescue some sense from it what do you
say and at the point that we run out of
confusion in portland we're going to
talk about covid
we are not going to run out of confusion
we may have to call a halt to our
discussion of the confusion in portland
in order to get to the confusion
surrounding covid
but let's just say there's plenty of
confusion to go around there sure is
yeah all right so portland you've heard
lots of things about what's going on in
portland and you've heard some
some efforts by us to try to uh correct
the uh distortion
but i wanted to start with a couple of
concepts all right
the first one has to do with
verificationism which is something that
you and i have thought an awful lot
about in a scientific context
and the reason it's relevant here is
that
a verificationist approach to sense
making
in science is devastatingly broken
because it is very often that you can
find
evidence for a perspective in spite of
the fact that the perspective is false
whereas if you seek to find evidence
against a perspective and it is false
you will find
more of that and you will disconfirm it
and it is only when you find an
explanation for something so robust
that you can't find disconfirming
evidence that you really know you're on
to something
and for fans of the history of
epistemology who are out there
uh we can attribute the origin of this
idea to carl popper to karl popper
exactly so
a poparian view is a falsificationist
view and all of those of us who pay
attention to the
philosophy of science which is a little
bit of a dry discipline but a very
important one
we know that verificationists are a
thing to be feared and what i see taking
place
in the news cycle is
verificationist myth making which is
resulting in
completely divergent and unreconcilable
portrayals of
events that are factual which should be
able to be reported
and then interpreted by viewers instead
they are being pre-interpreted
through a verificationist lens leaving
viewers to have
totally discordant understandings of
what took place and therefore have no
ability
to join together and discuss what to do
about it i've got one perfect example of
this
all right i know you're going somewhere
important but one of the things i wanted
to
show was this sack if you would put this
up from harper's weekly review
from today the very first sentence
violent clinton this is harper's
magazine one of one of the
you know biggest best oldest most
important monthly magazines of news and
culture
in the united states violent clashes
between police brutality protesters and
law enforcement officers broke out in
several american cities it says
and protests continued in portland
oregon where the trump administration
has deployed members of the border
patrol tactical unit
vortech a unit that normally conducts
high-risk grades against smugglers along
the border
two counter demonstrators equipped with
umbrellas bicycle helmets
and pool noodles wow pool noodles it
says
that does sound like a bit of an
overreaction uh yeah
yeah how why on earth should the uh
members of the border patrol tactical
unit be uh sent in as a response to
people armed with
pool noodles soon noodles yeah pool
noodles don't seem all that dangerous or
destructive
i noticed that absent from that
description is anything about
uh nightly arson about
projectiles being launched explosives
lasers being pointed into the eyes of
the officers all those things seem to be
absent
power tools being brought in to take
down the the barriers erected
and um even just uh when we were when we
went down there
on saturday night um things like hockey
sticks i didn't see any pool noodles but
i'd see hockey sticks not a single pool
noodle no
yeah um so we weren't there late enough
for the pool noodles
wow they only break out the full noodles
when the thing really gets going
um yeah so it is interesting to be here
in portland to be able to observe
the events directly right and then to
read about them
in publications that you have subscribed
to and understand that there is actually
no reality to what is being portrayed
now i will say i see some of this on the
other side too
right we sometimes hear that you know
portland is in flames which is
absolutely
not the case most of portland is
unaffected
there is a large area in downtown that
has
damage evident from the initial riots
um but the nightly it's not two square
blocks it's much more than that but it's
also
not all of portland and this is actually
this is the point when we were down
there on saturday night with our friend
nancy roman she was in town to to report
from
you know city that had been her home for
15 years and this is this was
her first thought upon arriving wow
where where she landed
was calm and beautiful as is the pacific
northwest in the summer
and then you go down to this place at
the right moment
and it does not look like a peaceful
protest
um well sometimes it does but then again
i think what one has to understand is
that
the protest like all protests is
interested in
cultivating and understanding now there
are honorable honorable protests in
which the understanding that is being
cultivated
is in some sense an accurate
representation of something
but it can also be done deceptively yep
and
in this case what we have is a reliable
pattern
in which a peaceful protest
becomes a riot at some point in the
evening
violence breaks out attacks on these
buildings
break breakout and what we are seeing
is a portrayal of events that takes
one bit of license and buys everything
with it that one piece of license is
that the cause and effect
have been inverted so
the portrayal you will see is that the
federal government
has attacked a peaceful protest and that
is resulting in riots when in fact
what we have is a city refusing to
enforce its own laws and we've seen this
ourselves downtown there's uh no poli no
normal police presence around these
buildings
we have uh seen and heard of crimes
being committed there there are some
that are evident
right in the park across the street and
nobody's doing anything about them so
the law is manifestly not being
enforced and the attacks the nightly
attacks on the buildings necessitate
some response now the response could be
let these people destroy these federal
buildings now of course the federal
government has a mandate not to allow
that to happen
but given that the local police will not
step in we have to ask what is it that
is supposed to happen
right and to your point about cause and
effect being reversed
uh the fact is that if you just look at
the timeline the riots precede the
sending in
of additional federal troops there are
apparently always
federal troops inside the federal
buildings because it is their job to
defend them always and usually no one
knows about them thinks about them
hears them seize them anything but the
the tenor of the protests now is almost
entirely
about getting the feds out and in fact
you know this this
might be the moment to show a couple of
the videos from from last night or from
from saturday night rather
um but the fact is that the riots
precede
the presence of the new federal officers
in portland therefore
this cannot be responsive to the new
federal officers being in portland
it's it just it just doesn't work at a
simple chronological level at a simple
chronological level and you have to ask
the question about
why it is that federal property is under
attack that has a meaning and in this
case i think it actually has two
meanings which is
um one that there is actually
antipathy for the united states it's
visible in much of the graffiti and
there is a
very naive belief that the united states
is some kind of unique evil in the world
and that it must be undone so attacking
federal property makes symbolic sense
if that was your perspective but also
there is a clear desire to precipitate a
response
from the trump administration that can
be portrayed as
authoritarian overreach in order to
justify
the violent behavior on the part
of these self-described progressives
and so the whole thing is theater
so do you want to show some of those uh
yeah zach you want to start uh
just by showing the photograph that i
sent you of the uh
right outside the federal building the
the site of all of this that is
happening
um someone flying a flag and there were
a few of these someone flying an
american flag upside down
um such that it was easy to capture the
you know federal building some of the
graffiti on it
and the the fence that's been erected
around it and
uh you know this is this is a a clear
frankly [ __ ] america symbol well throw
it
uh flying the flag upside down i think
it's one step
more clever than that that is a
um an artifact designed for a
verificationist viewpoint
if you hate america you can find it in
the flying of that flag upside down
if you love america and you think it
needs to do better if you think things
are screwed up
you can also find it in that upside down
flag and so i think i suppose
it's actually it looks it looks i mean i
i feel like i'm a patriot who feels like
america can do better for sure
and uh and that has of course always
been true and is probably always true
for any complex uh political system but
clearly we could be doing we could be
doing better and could have been doing
better and yet
it never would have occurred to me to uh
display or try to communicate any kind
of actual patriotism by
flying a flag upside down well let me
put it to you this way
if you burn a flag it's pretty
unambiguous what you mean
right if you fly a flag upside down i
truly believe that the
even just the part of the mind that
understands that to be a patriotic
symbol
gets conflicting messages and you will
be allowed to read into it whatever it
is
that you want to read into it which is
part of the problem here is that
almost everybody who is making excuses
for what's going on in portland and
elsewhere
is seeing what they want to see right
they've had a verificationist message
put in front of them
they've had ambiguity placed where they
can do their own
some assembly required version of events
in which
you know this is peaceful protest it's
an honorable
tradition in america it is what the
first amendment is about
right except for the fact that there's a
reliable pattern in which
the peaceful protest descends into
violence each and every night against a
federal building
so um anyway verificationism is
is is the uh the core here yeah i think
that's right
zach if you want to show maybe just 10
seconds or so of the
of the video that's darker that i that i
sent you
in which they're chanting
[Music]
uh hopefully we couldn't hear that but
hopefully there was enough
being shown there that you could hear
the chance which is this sort of
atonal nasal all cops are bastards a
c a b all cops are bastards a c
a b this is not during the part of the
evening that things
began to unravel actually this is during
what is
you know would be widely considered the
peaceful protest and yet that is the
chant
that is that is the chant it is clearly
divisive
and hateful and dehumanizing and
has no chance of reaching across borders
between demographics and then finally
um the other video zach that i sent you
which is a laser there's no reason i can
talk over the sound on this because
i'll just describe for those people that
are not watching
there's a laser show of a
on the federal building maybe show it
again zach
of uh of a pig
[Music]
wearing a police hat with x'ed out eyes
that then becomes [ __ ] fence
that's what it says this is being
projected from the roof of a car
at ground level onto the building there
are several projections on to the
building
yeah uh and uh
there's there's no way to unite
to imagine that the people
that are inside that building defending
it
could come to be your friends or allies
when this is the messaging that's out
there
yeah it is designed to be an
unbridgeable
gap it is designed to make this
manifestation of our collective self
the federal government into the enemy
which is of course preposterous and the
reason that this
is desired and plausible has to do with
trump lightning rod who couldn't
possibly take an action
that would be read as the right one if
you name an action and you say that's
what he should have done and then he
does it
it will instantly become uh overreach in
the minds of those
uh drawing this verificationist um
portrayal um did you want to go on to
that or
it's up to you i just thought you might
be going there uh we'll go there in a
second okay um
actually maybe we should go there first
the wall of moms okay so
uh let me say i encountered the wall of
moms
for the first time as i was riding my
bike through
downtown to get home um
and i passed by the protests and just
wanted to see what it was about and the
wall of moms was there i think it might
have been their second night
in existence a week ago today yeah and
i must say that in looking at the wall
of moms my conclusion
was much what we had heard from the
couple of people we knew who had seen it
in the previous iteration which was that
there were people in the crowd who
looked like they might be moms but that
the majority of these people
looked like they weren't likely to be
moms and they were just donning yellow
shirts and of course
if you think about this from the
perspective of a protest that's trying
to make a visual point
why would this be restricted to moms
when the idea is that these are
these are people who identify as moms
for the purpose of uh
making the uh response by the federal
government
look un-american right and when we were
down there
three nights ago uh we saw the the sort
of
embankment of moms before they became
the wall of moms before they marched in
front of the
federal courthouse uh and and did the
performative part of what they do which
you know i don't think anyone's denying
that
right that it's it's clearly
performative but uh what is being called
into question what we're calling into
question and what you know donald trump
called into question a lot of other
people
um is is it organic are
are these moms who felt you know the
the cry from the heart of of these other
mothers who've had their children
slaughtered by racial violence at the
hands of police
um out there on the streets to decry
that
i suspect that there are some people out
there who really did feel that
and are out there but um i think it
nearly impossible that explains everyone
and i think it quite possible and at
least a hypothesis we need to be
considering
that this isn't organic that it didn't
start that way at all and
to that point um i would suggest just
just like we spent some time looking at
the official black lives matter site
here's there's an official all the wall
of mom's site
uh so zach if you can show this um
it it you know begins with the hashtag
blacklivesmatter which is at least in
keeping that's on message
right and it says it says what we're
going to do but
um check out the bullet points it's not
as egregious as the black lives
matter website but it's all the same
language that we've been learning from
robin d'angelo and abram kindy
and all of this critical theory and
critical race theory stuff
we listen to black leaders we are here
to follow their direction behind the
scenes and at the justice center we go
where they tell us
that's ally ship in 2020 which is not of
course ally shep it is
a form of uh
subjugation yeah our goal it continues
is to push the media to turn the focus
where it belongs black leaders
well really because wala bomb seems to
be taking a lot of the the press at the
moment
we will use our white bodies not our
white voices
again with this dehumanization focus on
body stuff
um bev who was the founder of olive's
mom's
vision was that we moms would take some
physical hits and hopes that our black
and brown kids friends neighbors and
loved ones would be spared some pain
to summon that mom warrior spirit to
protect our kids all our kids let the
feds feds and cops hit gas shoot us
first not to be the voice of the
movement
this is this is picking up on not just a
trope but a
reality that actual mothers have right
that you know mother human mothers bear
mothers all mothers who have an actual
relationship with their children which
is that they
will actually put themselves in harm's
way to protect their children
and under certain circumstances um
that can be that mature that deep
abiding like deeper than anything else
maternal
instinct if you will instead probably
isn't the right word here but can be
placed onto other other targets
but um this feels very much like a ploy
and uh in the last live stream i
mentioned
naseem taleb's coining of the term
pedofrosty i think it was in which he he
said
this is what happens when you use
children to front
an ideology and it it plucks at the
heartstrings of people
because you can't turn your your head or
away or your heart or your emotions away
from
from a child and a child's um you know
yearning to be heard
and to have justice done and so i
suggested that actually metro
frasty is also a thing that that is what
is going on here that it's really hard
when people are when people are making
the claim that this is a
this is this is a lot of moms in
portland who are seeing the pain of
black and brown bodies really not people
bodies okay black and brown bodies and
going out there and putting themselves
in harm's way you know presumably
at risk of if if we are to believe
the hyperbole frankly at risk of
orphaning their own children
because they feel this strongly i'm kind
of not buying it
yeah i'm just not buying it i don't buy
it either and you know there's a general
pattern here
which is you've got a movement that is
advocating
an absolutely radical transformation
of the way we interact with each other
yeah
i have the sense it is hiding behind
black people that that's what this is
that the anarchism at the heart
of what is being advocated is really the
point tear it down and the great thing
will emerge which is of course nonsense
as
we will see here in a second but um but
it's hiding behind things that are
unassailable
mom is unassailable and if you want to
say you know what
i looked at those moms they didn't look
like moms to me then the question is
well
are you saying they're not old enough to
be moms of course they're old enough to
be moms but i'm telling you
i have some sense of what moms look like
it didn't look like a collection of moms
to me
it looks like a collection when you
stand back enough to see a wall of
yellow shirts
and so you know it looks it looks very
much like
uh someone with a lot of pr background
or a pr firm was brought in to say okay
let's you know let's invoke moms let's
invoke apple pie you know is that next
yeah baseball mom's apple pie the whole
thing is going to be used to defend
i was thinking you know baseball
unfortunately i'm thinking about the
baseball bats
um among the the rioters that uh
in evergreen you know like obviously
baseball bats
can be used as weaponry so it's it's
harder to invoke here as
some sort of an act you know the actual
americans are
fighting the gestapo they're being
called right the federal officers are
being called the gestapo
yeah they are and you know the problem
is of course if you
start as so many of these press reports
do if you start with the dramatic
images of the of the uh the
um tear gas floating over
the pavement with these heavily armed
you know
officers marching at these protesters
who you've been told
are peaceful and then they get fired
upon and it's like
well okay yeah that's a very ugly thing
that's happening except that that's not
what's happening
and it's it's very troubling but
remember
we've got local authorities not
enforcing the law
we've got an attack on a federal
building which is
completely non-random they have chosen a
federal building
because they want a federal response
right and if you had any doubt about
that
i just saw right before we went live
today
that there was apparently an attack on
the federal building in eugene
right so eugene is a much smaller town
than portland
and there are presumably no federal
officers there yet um my guess is there
are a few
a few inside right but no no one's been
deployed to protect it so you know
what's
what's the attack based on fed's out of
eugene they're not here yet right beds
out of eugene of course though we'll
probably be told that this is in
solidarity with the
protesters in portland but the fact is
if you're here watching this unfold and
you're watching oh
the cops are not enforcing the law oh
the attack is narrowed
to one part of downtown oh it's narrow
to the federal building
right now just one of the federal
buildings too right and walking back to
our car you pointed out oh there's
there's another federal building it's
got some graffiti on it and it
shouldn't but there's no there's no
protesters there right
and actually um and the city is actually
cryptically
signing up with the anarchists which is
the most bizarre thing in the world but
you've got
i showed the notice last time of the
indicator that the barrier that is the
last line of defense that does not
involve
federal officers putting themselves in
harm's way the last line of defense is
this substantial metal fence that has
been
erected to protect the building the city
is now telling
the federal government that it is
violating it is impeding traffic which
is
technically true but not meaningfully
true traffic still passes on that street
well and i mean frankly not having
finally been down there which i hadn't
been
before uh at least from whatever it was
9 to 11 at night on a saturday night on
a street that normally would have
traffic on it
um traffic is impeded all right but it's
not by offense right i mean like it's
it's actually it's impeded by the
thousands of people
in the streets and by some cars that
have
uh that have lined up precisely to block
traffic and you know maybe
you know i can see an argument for this
preventing
some [ __ ] from driving through and
trying to kill people yep
right i think that's what it is but the
point is the idea that i mean
traffic is very much blocked right well
it's blocked during the hours
of the protest during the day traffic
flows um
the city has now put the federal
government on alert that it can't have
its fence there
and as i mentioned last time i was told
that they also can't move it back so
it's out of traffic because then it will
violate the americans with disabilities
act right but what i found out today
is that apparently there is a
fine of something like is 500
every 15 minutes somehow i believe
a couple hundred thousand dollars in
fines have apparently
been levied against this barrier by the
city against the federal government
i mean the whole thing is preposterous
right what what is supposed to happen is
the fence supposed to come out and then
the people who
throw stuff over the fence to light the
fires every day are supposed to have
direct access
to the building in order to light the
fires in the building which they have
done a number of times
like what what exactly is the city
thinking
um and you know are we trying to secede
because i think that they would have or
oregon or i don't even know what this is
supposed to mean
right we are right no that's i mean
that's that's a big thing right it's
it's incoherent what actually is it that
people claim that they want
because you know the the reason i showed
the you know the two videos
that i did that those struck me as the
most salient examples of what was going
on down there
is it's this you know all cops are
bastards and [ __ ] feds
like that that's what this is now the
wall of mom's site leads with black
lives matter but
it's all this jumbled mess that frankly
leads to anarchism
and you know my my overwhelming sense
being down there
was sadness yeah just
just sadness the bleakest
it was so bleak and you know that that
chant
that i displayed for us was actually the
most
musical of all of them like it was so
awful and sad and
it also clearly was replacing bars and
clubs and parties for people
right 100 it's the only thing to do and
so it's
it is getting a lot of energy because
people are bored out of their minds
and uh yeah it's it and i agree with you
that ultimately the only coherent
explanation for what is being demanded
and attempted and all of those things
is anarchism that's the only coherent
rationale and you know it's not coherent
as
a plan it won't work right and in fact
zach could you put up the um
the riot ribs picture
so unfortunately i don't have anything
beyond this picture here this is the
former
riot ribs which is an illegal
uh vendor of ribs in the park across
from the hatfield
courthouse which apparently accumulated
three hundred thousand dollars in
donations people
um supporting riots
via ribs that are free to people who are
are there writing takes calories no
doubt it does
um the trash from this operation has
been launched over the fence
nightly and lit a fire so this is a
externalizing
force but an autonomous rib joint it is
an autonomous rib joint
apparently in an autonomous uh an
undeclared autonomous zone
right across from the the courthouse but
here's the thing
in the last day or two
riot ribs has uh left
they have just vaporized they have
vaporized after having collected
three hundred thousand dollars and they
have vaporized
as a result of some sort of conflict
where before they vaporize they alleged
that somebody was attempting to profit
by using the idea of riot ribs and it's
not well explained
what took place but somehow some
internal conflict
inside riot ribs whatever it may be has
caused
riot ribs to say not only are we
closing up shop but anybody who's
dispensing ribs there is not a good
person and you shouldn't
go anywhere near this operation which
raises obvious questions
and then somebody else i mean sorry but
i mean there were there are a lot of
barbecues down there a lot of people
cooking
cooking meat for people it appears right
i have no idea how much of that is riot
ribs and how much of it might
i think much of it wasn't but the idea
that you know if
if this movement is anything like what
it claims to be about the idea of
other people also trying to feed hungry
people being
being not okay is clearly a rejection of
their stated ideals
well the thing is every time they enact
their anarchism they prove our point
about the problem with anarchism right
right they always tell us that it's
going to work out and then it always
breaks down
into garbage and violence and all of
these things so
an activist a local activist has tweeted
about the riot ribs conflict and she has
basically declared who the good people
are and who the bad people are
and advised the world don't you dare
call the cops on this we have to start
living our
values of settling our own yadda yadda
and the point is look
i don't know who's good who's bad what
the 300 000
is where it's going to end up i couldn't
tell you whether they're
any good people in the story whether
they're a good people and bad people
but the point is the whole idea that you
are going to operate
an operation like riot ribs under
anarchist rules and that this is not
a neon sign invitation to bad actors to
step
in to whatever process stream you have
generated
of course this is going to happen what
do you need in order to address the
problem
you would need a court what are they
attacking they're attacking the court
they are telling us they don't
understand
how it is that decency is allowed to
flourish right right no
i mean and frankly the idea that um in
if if this were what harpers would have
us believe
for instance and i'm really mourning
that that harpers went here as well
you know i've unfortunately come to
expect this sort of thing from npr in
the new york times and such but okay
harper's great
um what
what is it that we are actually supposed
to believe
like they they are giving us
such incomprehensible nonsense
well they are giving us incomprehensible
nonsense
the other side is getting it closer to
right because they
it's closer to their home narrative
right that this has left us out of
control which it is
um but but you but you know what the
others the other side right you know the
right
won't say hey look at the
entrepreneurial spirit
of riot ribs which you know one of the
things that i thought when i was
listening to you saying well you it's
illegal well i'm sure it's illegal of
course it's illegal the whole thing is
illegal
yeah but were this actually coming up on
60 days
of peaceful protests as opposed to
peaceful protests that quickly ceded
uh to uh nightly riots
then i would expect the entrepreneurial
spirit of some people
out there who actually know how to make
food and there are a lot of people in
portland who know how to make good food
to show up and either donate
their time and resources or at least
try to try to not end up in debt from it
or maybe make a profit
right like there's not there's nothing
wrong with that but
you know the the the founders of black
lives matter would say oh there is
something wrong with that because we're
trained at marxism and we don't believe
in
profit so right ribs appears to have
just shuttered up
shop with something like 300 000 in
donations who knows where that went
was this just exactly the same kind of
entrepreneurial spirit with
a bad actor that you know it if without
the bad actors we celebrate this
in the united states except that these
protesters would claim that they don't
celebrate it because
making a profit off of your own hard
work and ingenuity is somehow not okay
except right ribs just appears to have
done that like the entire thing is
a mess on top of a mass on top of a mess
well in effect
they're going to destroy everything and
then if
it is possible to build after that if
they do not destroy things in a way
that prevents us from ever returning
yeah they will reinvent
all of the things that they claimed were
insane to begin with
and the fact is the cost on the way
there will be
uh unimaginable right right no i mean
and it's not it's not that it wouldn't
be wonderful
if there were another possible
way to run a society you know and it's
it's not
that 10 000 years ago democracy
was understood right this these are
inventions of humanity
and evolving processes but
nothing that i have heard out of any of
their mouths
or on any of the websites suggest
anything but burn it down
and if there's any political ideology at
all at the base it ends up being marxist
which is a complete redistribution
complete redistribution yeah which we
know doesn't work for game theoretic
reasons that are
pretty simple and of course uh that
requires that you accept that logic is
something that one can wield and of
course
they go after logic so you know it's it
this is the second concept that i think
is central here so verificationism is
the first
autoimmunity is the second this is an
attack on everything that makes
something
functional that makes a system above a
certain size
functional and um
you you cannot humor it
right and the problem is many people
because of the verificationism issue if
you accept that this is autoimmunity
so you want to spell that out a little
bit i mean i think you know we're
biologists i get what you mean but maybe
you spell it out okay
justice depends on the fact that people
who refuse to abide
by the rules suffer a penalty great
enough that they do not come to dominate
now i'm not saying that this works
perfectly there are levels of our system
that actually do
uh reward those who game the system
in their own favor but at the level of
like the laws
against violence it is important to your
ability to walk down the street safely
to our kids ability to go to school
it is important that if somebody shows a
propensity
for violence that they face
greater violence that something is able
to take them away and in fact
i wish i had it here but there was a
piece of video circulating a week ago
in which a black guy
clearly nuts in some way portland or no
yeah
okay walked into oh i'm not sure it was
portland
actually i am sure it was portland i'm
sorry about that he walked into what was
represented as a laundromat looked like
a very big laundromat
and he was he was holding a
a saw like a a saw for cutting wood
and he not a power tool though just like
a hacksaw or something not a hacksaw
a big traditional wood saw
and you can see he walks in he walks up
to the two women who were working there
and literally attacks them with the saw
okay
and this is caught on the cam's on the
cctv
yeah cam's in the shop he then walks out
and the story goes
the re the part that is not caught on
film is that apparently
protesters tried to interfere with
his arrest right on the basis that he
was black and these were cops and we all
know that when
cops there can be only one way that
justice is served
right so this is a very forever elect
never arrest black people even when they
have done crime
right i mean i don't know such an insane
rubric it's insane this is a violent act
with it you know how do i mean how are
the women how are the employees
it's a little hard to say i mean but in
any case
this apparently happened and what it
tells you
is you know what you need
to have police that have the ability to
detain somebody and take them away
when they show a propensity for violence
you just simply do
and if you take that away then what you
get is you end up with rule by those
who are violent right so the monopoly on
violence concept is really important
government is a monopoly on violence
which doesn't mean
that there has to be violence but it
means you can't
everybody decide whether they want to be
violent or not this hour or that
right you have to have some authority
you have to have the rules spelled out
and so it seems to me like your two
concepts for today
verificationism and autoimmunity are
mechanisms by which
this cultural ponzi scheme which we
introduced in the last episode functions
that's that's how it that's how it does
its business yes it invalidates
all of the mechanisms that would stand
in its way
and so um you know you need the police
to arrest people who attack a federal
building
but you can actually persuade the city
and the state not to do it
right that's really a shocking
development but basically
you pressure the city and the state
through all kinds of things through
you know mocking the
mayor as if he was a child on a
schoolyard
right so you've got that you've got
doxing you've got all kinds of things
that have people making decisions that
clearly they shouldn't but they do
and then there's some last line of
defense but you know
you need courts what do you do in court
you
use logic applied in the context of law
that is publicly understood in order to
establish the facts of what took place
and whether or not it was a violation
if you say logic hey that's white people
stuff you're cooked
right how do you establish if there's
bias if you say you know what this
society is biased
well how are you going to establish that
without logic without science without
statistics without all sorts of things
that you've now declared are off limits
because you claim that they themselves
are tools of oppression it's not as
opposed
to the more nuanced but actually true
claim
that those tools logic and science and
statistics
have historically been less available to
groups including black people and women
and you know other groups that we are
currently recognizing as historic
historically oppressed and that
reduced access has created situations
such that it is perhaps
harder to access them now for some for
some people through no fault of their
own
that is true right that is a totally
different claim which uses almost all
the same words
well right that's that's that's kind of
the trick and maybe it's actually the
source of the confusion
for many of the people involved in these
protests and these riots
so at bottom right if we take
the movement seriously
it is having the inverse reaction that
i think any logical person would have
to the problem of unfairness
being non-randomly distributed the
solution is obviously to democratize all
the most useful stuff and make sure it
is as widely distributed as possible
the problem with that is it does not
guarantee equal outcomes
right equal access does not guarantee
equal outcomes and i think people
much more than i do and i think you do
fear
that if you were to make access truly
equal that there would still be wildly
different outcomes which i think there'd
be wildly different preferences
but i don't think there'd be wildly
different capacities right but those but
those wildly different preferences would
lead to some different outcomes
especially when we're talking about sex
men men versus women
and i think actually this fear is part
of what has led to the
completely wrong confused idea that i've
actually seen promoted by
people who are credentialed in science
you know phd scientists
who say things like if if we are
equal then the only possible explanation
for differences in outcome
is discrimination no yeah which is wrong
wrong wrong and equal doesn't mean the
same
right but if you fear what happens if
you had
absolutely thoroughly democratized
access to everything good and useful
yeah if you fear that then you go the
other way
and the other way is harrison bergeron
you can get to equality through
hobbling hence the attack on everything
useful right you can deny
everybody access to logic and then there
won't be differential outcomes well
of course there will because there will
be ethical differences in how many rules
you're willing to violate in order to
get ahead
then you end up with these durge-like
atonal chants
because no one is left with the
possibility of beauty or joy or actual
justice
right and you end up with warlords
because the basic point is those who are
willing to
avail themselves of every opportunity no
matter how immoral come out on top
so that's the world we are being invited
to but can you show the um
the tweet i sent you about the lawsuit
and then we probably need to move to
covet
yeah so here you can see
project democracy is
um tweeting that they have just sued the
administration that is to say the trump
administration
on behalf of don't shoot pdx and the
wall of moms
to make sure that the rights of
protesters are protected
it's time for you to stop attacking
patriots now i find that last line
chilling
because while there may be some patriots
in this movement the movement
is overwhelmingly anti-american
not only implicitly but in many cases
explicitly
you know that upside down flag
definitely
is not um it is what you will make of it
but
the people who are flying it are flying
it for a reason and it is not about
patriotism
um so anyway what is it that these uh
lawyers think they are seeing that they
are tweeting
about this is uh they are filing a
lawsuit to stop this attack on patriots
what is it that they would have happen
right you've got lawyers no but you know
there's one
one such suit was recently struck down
by a judge finding that
um actually it whatever was happening
with regard to federal officers
who were turns out identified as federal
officers but not with their names
pulling people off the streets into
unmarked vehicles yes they were unmarked
was not itself a violation so that that
suit has been struck down
and you know we could we can argue about
whether or not that was appropriate but
actually
it you know it went to a court of law
and it it
the evidence was assessed yep and i
should say i don't think
this happened in time for our last live
stream but we now know
that the um description that we
uh provided on this podcast for what was
taking place what explained people being
pulled
into unmarked rented vehicles in
portland
that now appears to have been the
accurate understanding
of what took place which is to say
nothing of whether or not there's a
violation in it
right but it does appear that um people
were involved in
criminal activity they were presumably
filmed involved in that activity but
their identity was not i
was not ascertainable from a distance
they were then picked up brought into a
cell
where their identity was established and
then they were released and federal
indictments
were sought and then issued against them
so the point is is this some wild
gestapo
overreach it certainly isn't that this
is a normal federal process
functioning where the local and state
process
has clearly not only failed but is now
acting
as part of this autoimmunity it doesn't
even appear to have failed it just
didn't try
it like it failed to fail it somehow was
boxed into failing socially and
politically which is a frightening thing
that that can happen is just terrifying
yeah yeah well should we uh should we
pivot a little bit
yeah to a more hopeful subject oh good
yeah so well i mean actually
there's there's a common theme here
which is
do true things become untrue when people
you don't like sam
right so we don't like trump we've made
that very clear
um but trump says the wall of moms is
not what it seems we already showed you
that
no we don't we need to show that again
um yeah i think that's right
right trump has also been as we now
pushing hydroxychloroquine as a
treatment for covet 19
since very early on now we have in you
know
probably episodes 1 through 18
frequently critiqued
trump's response on covet 19. he did a a
very poor job
in many many regards but he was pushing
hydroxychloroquine early
there was not tremendous evidence
at that point now and you know it's it's
it's still
it's still a question and of course this
virus is evolving rapidly and so what
works now
may not work in the future but here we
have uh
zach if you want to show this um an
article written a few days ago on the
23rd of july
by a professor of epidemiology at the
yale school of public health who's an md
phd
who is making the point and he
references an article that
i can also pull up probably we won't
hear
in which he reviews uh the scientific
and medical literature
for uh hydroxychloroquine and finds it
to be highly efficacious
when delivered early in the course of
the disease which is what you would
expect
um not not late once once you have uh
pretty high viral load and um are well
into symptoms
but specifically he says that evidence
for the cocktail of hydroxychloroquine
zithromax and zinc um is highly
effective now
is this will this turn out to be true i
don't i don't know for sure
of course he points to this actually
zach you want to put this up
um this is the peer-reviewed
article in the american journal journal
of epidemiology published in the end of
may actually this is
fully two months ago and uh he
it's basically a review article in which
he looks at the
you know scant but growing evidence
uh that this is actually an effective
treatment so
this has been one of the most obviously
politicized aspects of covet
right we've been talking since since the
beginning
about the about masks and i have a few
things to say about masks but you know
since march 24th when we first began
this
uh we've been saying actually ignore
what the who says ignore the us surgeon
general you you should be wearing masks
because that is going to be effective
and
and lo and behold um this virus is not
unlike every other respiratory virus out
there but masks are actually effective
in
preventing transmission um
because trump has been pushing
hydroxychloroquine
the left media and therefore fully half
the country
have basically decided there's no chance
it could be true
as as if medicine cares about your damn
politics
yeah it it's um it's absurd
and one wonders how so many people have
fallen
into this obviously wrong belief system
that the fact of trump saying something
makes it wrong right i mean in fact
um first of all
i think it is important that we step
back
um years it used to be
regularly said and implied
that trump was hit
right so you're not talking about
decades you're just talking about a
couple of years
i'm talking about a few years at the
point that trump took office
it was very common for people on the
left to assert that this was
the next version of this historical
pattern
i never hear anybody tell me oops we got
that wrong
but right they just simply step into
this next
phase of everything trump is wrong
and um i must say that it does not do
much
for my confidence and their opinion
because obviously to the extent that
trump is
a cynical actor which i think he
frequently is to the extent that he's a
political actor which i think he always
is if i have one
central criticism of him and one reason
that i believe he absolutely
must be removed from office it's that he
politicizes
everything you know including the
hydroxychloroquine of course
thing but it doesn't make it false right
and if you
award him the weapon of if you
say it we will reject it then you have
lost
yep right you have been gamed you've
been game you've been trolled you've
been gamed you lose
right so yeah a smart player i mean you
don't even have to be very smart you
just have to be a tiny bit smart
to understand you cannot sign up for
that rule right if trump says it
you don't know if it's right or wrong
i'd sign up for that but
if trump says it it's wrong is you
surrendering it may be
one of the biggest sources of belonging
for a lot of people in the country right
now
i think that is one of the appeals at
this point the where in the club we're
in the tribe
that knows that trump is evil and won't
all the problems be gone if only we get
rid of that
and you know of course all you have to
do is look at the messaging
of the protests and know that that that
isn't
actually what will happen but a lot of
people are so
so seeking something to belong to and
the
anti-trump crowd is is one that in
in many in many social groups is a safe
one
and actually it would be quite unsafe
you'd feel pretty bereft and alone
if you said something to the contrary
yeah and in fact you know the funny
thing about
um this podcast and the social world
that it is
a part of is that we attempt
to exist in the reality middle ground
where there's
very little cover right yeah to the
extent that one has to say
actually trump got this one right it's
like oh you're one of them you're a
closet
trumper right and to the extent you say
no he politicizes everything oh you have
trump derangement syndrome
yeah and so the point is you know it's a
very quick way to just
take almost everybody and eliminate them
from
the ability to have a conversation but
it leaves a small number of people who
are willing to try to navigate that
um very much in your in your male you
and i wouldn't want to be anywhere else
but
there's a question about how safe it is
right because
the problem is both sides are demonizing
the middle for their own purposes
and um you know that's all well and good
as long as it stays on twitter i guess
but the problem is this is 2020 and a
lot of stuff appears to be spilling over
into the real
yeah it's not clear to me that what
happens on twitter stays on twitter yeah
no it clearly clearly doesn't yeah
let me say a few more a few more things
on uncovered yeah let's do that
all right so um here zach we have a
paper published called a country level
analysis measuring the impact of
government actions country preparedness
and socioeconomic factors on covet 19
mortality and related health outcomes
it's a long title
but basically it's a massive uh
retrospective study trying to assess how
country-level policies affected both
caseloads
of covid and outcomes uh once
once people are infected and there's
some surprising things here and you know
this hasn't this has only been out for a
few days
i have not fully vetted it the way i did
a few of the earlier papers back in
april and may um but let me just read
the findings here absent the statistics
increasing covert 19 caseloads were
associated with countries with higher
obesity
median higher median population age and
longer time to border closures from the
first reported case
so higher case loads in basically fatter
countries older countries and countries
that didn't close their borders fast
okay that's one thing increased
mortality per million
was significantly so this is different
than caseload this is mortality per
million and not mortality per million of
people infected but mortality per
million
population mortality per capita was
significantly associated with again
higher obesity prevalence
and per capita gross domestic product
interesting
fatter and richer countries end up
having higher mortality rates
okay and that that's apparently true
when you correct for the association of
those two things
i believe so although like i said i have
not fully vetted
this is a complicated paper
reduced income dispersion reduced
mortality so that's a that's a strangely
written phrase what that means is
a a smaller spread on income basically
lower income inequality
means lower death rate the bigger the
spread the bigger the wealth inequality
which is to say
places like the us and brazil
had higher mortality rates and
also reduced income dispersion again
lower spread
reduced income inequality um was
associated with the number
lower number of critical cases a couple
couple more things
you want to respond to that well i'm
very curious about the uh
the wealth disparity is the increased
caseload
all on one end of the wealth disparity
you wouldn't expect it all to be there
but in other words are
are people who are comparatively
deprived more likely to get
sick and you does it result in a higher
absolute
perception if i had to guess just
actually off the top of my head
i suspect that that has to do with um
you can't get community transmission
until it's present
and so high wealth disparity requires
rich people
flying in from wherever they picked it
up and then they spread it because
they're shopping
and they infect clerks or or they're on
the subway or whatever
that that is what i suspect that's about
um okay you want to keep going yeah sure
uh rapid border closures full lockdowns
and widespread testing were not
associated with coba 19 mortality per
million people however
full lockdowns and reduced country
vulnerability to biological threats
were significantly associated with
increased patient recovery rates
so they weren't associated with the
number of infected people but they were
associated with better outcomes
exactly and just one more caveat from
this paper um
they say um despite appropriate public
health guidance less than optimal
population compliance in western
democracies
may be an important contributing factor
to variation in outcomes among the
various countries
that's science speak for uh countries
like
us are much less compliant at actually
following
medical orders than countries like
taiwan and south korea
yeah and of course the the deep
evolutionary irony
here which i think we cannot stress
enough is that in some sense this
there's an extreme
version of game theory playing out here
where any
non-compliant pocket is a place where
the virus can go
experiment and so we are in some sense
playing
with humanity's future with respect to
covid
by giving it more opportunities to learn
new tricks to evade
detection we're playing ball we are but
the point is
at some level to politicize this is the
height of insanity
yes right this is this is something in
which all of us have an interest
in uh you know in the swedes getting it
right
because even if everybody else got it
right and the swedes got it wrong then
this thing can
hide there in that refuge i mean picking
on the swedes just completely at random
but not completely around it because we
talked about the swedes earlier but
right but but the point is any community
that doesn't play by the rules any
country
um is providing a place where this thing
can get
better at avoiding our surveillance it
can get better at avoiding our treatment
and so at some level really this is the
place
this is the common enemy that is
supposed to bring us together
because game theoretically that's the
only right response and yet it is having
the opposite effect because it is
um for those who are looking for tools
in the political landscape it's
irresistible
so if aliens did actually land now yeah
and trump said
oh my god aliens have landed we must
respond then aliens didn't land we
wouldn't unify
we would we would not actually come
together
you're right this is just like i mean
that stems exactly from what you just
said this is supposed to be the common
enemy this is global
this is big this is real this is not a
political entity it is a viral entity
and it has done the opposite of unifying
us yeah it has done the exact opposite
and it's so it's tragic yeah to
to that point i i have to take a dig at
the new york times here because i cannot
believe them i
just cannot believe this um zach if you
want to put this up research boosts
evidence of mask's utility some experts
say masks have long been known to help
stop infected people from spreading the
virus
well like months but some research
suggests they
also protect the uninfected and then
there's a bullet point here masks may
also protect people wearing them
some experts say i don't want to get
down if you would say
um this you will you'll remember i
went off on a tirade last night when i
saw this i
can not believe the level
of scientific illiteracy and
frankly journalistic fraud in this the
we had the surgeon general and the who
telling us that masks
did no good at all with a respiratory
virus
then they came around and admitted that
that was actually a political move
designed to protect
the the short the the too few masks that
we had
so that health workers could use them
okay
but they insisted that you only wear a
mask to protect others from
you not you from others as if masks are
unidirectional
masks aren't unidirectional in fact
there are some masks that are
unidirectional you've all seen these the
little valves in them
they actually allow you to breathe your
viral particles out into the world and
it makes it a little bit more
comfortable to live inside of them
and they've been banned now at many
hospitals because it's exactly the
opposite of what you're supposed to be
doing but there is no mask
out there that i have ever heard of that
is unidirectional in the other direction
where you are breathing in all of the
particles
and not able to expel them so
the idea that we needed unnamed people
in lab coats
to tell us that masks might actually
both protect
you from others and others from you and
that this is
not even expec accepted enough that we
are being told some experts say it
my [ __ ] god like this this makes me
so mad of course half the country
doesn't want to wear a mask
of course this is politicized because
they are
no one knows how to think scientifically
and they are
appealing to authority for the most
basic fundamental ideas
put something over your mouth and you
won't spread droplets which might have
virus in them
put some something over your mouth and
you won't inhale droplets which might
have virus in them
yep there it is so i would just point
out
i mean it's obviously implicit in what
you're saying here but we nailed this
from the beginning and that's our very
first this is episode one it's
episode one and the point was i don't
know what kind of nonsense we are
hearing but obviously we're dealing with
a virus we don't know what it can do we
know it is transmitted
uh through inhaling droplets wear a mask
can't buy a mask make a mask it doesn't
have to be medical in nature bandana
works
just fine and so the point is look all
you have to be able to do is think
clearly
and what does think clearly require of
you well one thing it requires is if you
put politics aside
yes right um you know this is a my god
and very unfortunate if wonderful
vindication of the fact
that you know common sense will do it
yeah right common sense is enough just
basic training but you know but again
and again and again
wearing a mask to protect yourself from
particles
that are in droplets means that when
you're outside away from people you
don't need to wear a mask now could the
virus evolve
into something else yeah but this has
become
i've said it over and over and over
again this is star-bellied sneetches and
stages without
if you're wearing a mask you must be one
of us if you're not wearing a mask you
must be one of them
or flip it no you wear a mask when you
need to wear a mask inside with other
people whom you don't live with
all the time yep the other thing i would
point out
is that if you go back to our earliest
live streams about this
you will find that our model was not
nearly as good that we didn't know
enough
about how this thing was transmitted so
we were very concerned about things that
turn out to be very low likelihood of
transmitting it like um
i've still got copper on most of our
external doorknobs right right
which is certainly not going to hurt
yeah right but um
but not probably all that necessary and
the uh
you know the simple concern about
surfaces is probably overrated in
the case of this particular virus for
whatever reason could change
it could learn that trick but at the
moment that doesn't seem to be the
priority the priority seems to be
these airborne droplets it does seem to
be an issue of
the volume of the space you are in so
there's some kind of model that we've
developed where
there's a bucket and if you don't reach
the top of the bucket then even if
you're encountering virus
a particle is not going to get you
because your immune system can fend it
off
if you exceed the top of the bucket it
gets you so you wanna
you know this then creates the uh you
know the thing i worried about
downtown when we went to the protest was
outdoors high volume but if you were
downwind
of somebody who was sick then you might
fill that bucket up and you might
contract it which i you know i still
don't feel good about
having i think we needed to see the
protest but there's a risk in it that i
think is unacceptable which is
you couldn't control who was up up wind
of you that's right
and there's a lot of shouting a lot of
shouting exactly which we know to be
particularly bad but in any case i think
that you know the whole thing is an
argument for
don't over complicate this if somebody
is saying nonsense like
masks don't help you avoid this
respiratory virus they're probably full
of [ __ ] right
right exactly no that's that's exactly
right so just um
maybe two more things and i won't show
the papers um i'll put them in the
in the description of the video um two
more things that we are now
seeing that appear to be true but of
course this is you know this is an
evolving situation in terms of both the
data that we have coming in
and what the virus what is actually true
for the virus so both things
um can change one is that proton pump
inhibitors
things like um prilosec um
up here people who are on or or take
proton pump inhibitors
seem to be at increased risk for um
i think both if i if memory serves um
both getting and having bad outcomes
from covet 19.
and specifically if you take uh two or
more doses a day
you are at quite a higher risk and you
know it's still
it's still not a huge risk for most
people but um
quite a higher risk for people using
proton pump inhibitors and
frankly this strikes me as one yet one
more example
of uh how novelty is driving us into
uh into unhealthy lifestyles and
sickness
you have something to add there well i
just wanted to point out that actually
the proton pump
inhibitors if i understand it what they
are doing is they are
preventing they're lowering the ph of
the
gut environment so they deal with
stomach acid they deal with stomach acid
so basically the the code here is that
proton
is a hydrogen that has had its electron
slipped away uh stripped away leaving
only the proton
so it's h plus but the basic point is
that uh d so you've got a lot of h
pluses you're high acid when you've got
a lot of
oh slow ph so that low ph environment
is a hedge against pathogens
that's part of what it is right you eat
stuff it's partially compromised by
whatever got onto it
and you have this environment that
forces only that kills anything that's
not
capable of dealing with the extremes and
because it's coming from an environment
that isn't extreme
it's very unlikely that extremophiles
will be found on your food
and so it's a pretty good way of dealing
with most of the pathogens that you
would
consume and so anyway stands to reason
that something like a proton pump
inhibitor would get in the way of at
least some pathogen transmission
and our diet is such crap that many
people are
feeling the need to take these proton
pump inhibitors in order to have a
normal feeling gastrointestinal tract
and then that is putting them at risk
because they don't have the
onboard um pathogen resistant system
yeah i'm actually reminded this is going
to seem like it's coming out of left
field to everyone but you actually but
reminded one of the things i discovered
in madagascar with my frogs
these these these poison frogs reproduce
in these little the
bamboo wells that fill with water and
um among many other things that i was
doing i was trying to figure out what
might be distinct about the water
chemistry of the particular wells
frogs chose to reproduce and then the
males hung out and um
guarded the eggs and the tadpoles and um
the wells in which the frogs did best
and chose most often
were extremely acidic like enough so
that i actually
had to i didn't trust my data in one
season and came back with a different ph
meter and also
ph papers the next but no it was in like
the three to four range
like three to three point five actually
not even up to four whereas
across the board the ph was more like
five or six like it was a little bit
acidic but not much
like oh these frogs are choosing these
particularly ascetic wells presumably
because the pathogens that i was also
discovering were going after them
are doing less well in the wells um
the wells that are acidic so it's the
same kind of story
in you know the bamboo wells in
madagascar with poison frogs and our
stomach
so i think that in the case of the
proton pump inhibitors it raises a
question
about is there a hidden mode of
transmission so for example
if we know that mostly this is airborne
particles it's possible that you're
breathing in these particles
and then they hit your tongue and you
swallow them much more likely
that that would happen when you're
eating right yeah so is it that there's
covet on food that we're eating if so
which food
right so or is it you know it could even
be
that when you are eating you're masked
down
right and so maybe this increases the
chances that your
event will involve inhaling a viral
particle
and you know doing so as you're eating
and then you swallow it
and if your proton pumps are inhibited
then it has a much more uh it's much
more likely to get through your gut
um so anyway the point is look it's all
just logic
right that's right this is this is the
evolutionary logic yeah
this is the evolutionary logic and you
can just simply say well what's taking
place and the fact is you know the virus
itself
is a little black box and we're learning
how the little black box works but all
you really need to know is that there's
some particle
that contains instructions that's
capable of hijacking your cells
how is that particle getting into you
which cells does it attack what
measures can you take to prevent it from
getting in what measures can you take
that reduce its effectiveness once it's
once it's hijacked some of your cells
these are much simpler questions they're
not at the level at all of what goes on
inside the black box that's right well
maybe
yeah maybe maybe we stop there we come
back to some of the other
new coveted stuff next time all right
very good
um yeah so to sign off
we will be taking a 15-minute break and
coming back to answer your request to
your super chat questions
uh in the next hour and
if you are interested in access to a
private q a that we do once a month we
just did ours for july on sunday
you can join my patreon and become a
dark horse member there
you can access the discord server that
one of those dark horse members set up
that's private at either of our patreons
there's a clips channel where you can
find a lot of good clips from
the show and anything else you want to
say
yeah so we're reaching the end of the
month i don't know how that happened
because
end of yet another month where did the
year i guess time dilation is part of
this covet thing
unfortunately um but uh
reaching the end of the month which
means that we are closing in on
uh the next round of the discussions at
my patreon oh yes yes have been so
wildly popular and zach pointed me to a
comment somebody
made somewhere maybe on reddit wondering
whether or not these things were so
popular that you wouldn't be able to get
a word in edgewise i can say
that has not been the experience people
have found them very rewarding
it's lovely that there are more people
becoming aware of them and choosing to
sign up but
the group is very welcoming of new
people and the discussions have been
really high quality and i don't think
anybody has had the sense
that uh that they were sidelined so yeah
so those
um they're higher higher uh level 100
and 250
level but they will be actually saturday
this saturday from 10 to 12 pacific time
and sunday from 10 to 12 pacific time i
think
100 is saturday 2 50 is sunday with
slightly different
very different foci the first one is
about uh it's called the coalition of
the reasonable and it is about
um people interested in how civilization
might be
upgraded without attacking federal
buildings and destroying logic
and the other one is focused on
evolutionary dynamics
yeah great so those those will be
happening this weekend
for people who are interested and we'll
be back in 15 minutes
all right be well
you